now that we have found the solution to
the linear list mean squares estimation
problem it is time to offer a few
comments make some observations and
provide some insights the first
important observation is the following
in order to implement this estimator you
do not really need to know everything
about the distribution of X and theta
the only thing that you need to know is
the mean of the two random variables
that are involved the variance of X and
the covariance of theta with X so it's
only a few pieces of information that we
need and that means that we do not need
to be so careful about modelling in a
particular problem as long as we know
what the means variances and covariances
are this is a very desirable property
because it tells us that this could be
simpler to implement in the real world
now let us start looking at the form of
the solution and let's try to give some
interpretation suppose that the
correlation coefficient is positive then
what does this estimator do it starts
with a baseline estimate which is the
expected value of theta and then
provides us with a correction term
that's based on the data in particular
if it happens that we see an observation
that's larger than expected in that case
our estimate is going to be above the
expected value of theta so we start with
our baseline estimate but if we get a
big observation then our estimate will
also be large and conversely if X
happened to be on the lower side below
the expected value then our estimate
would also be below the expected value
of theta of course there's an analogous
story if Rho was negative then same
argument would apply except that it
would work in the opposite direction
when Rho is negative if we see a large X
then we will come up with a low estimate
for theta let us look at another special
case now suppose that Rho is equal to
zero X and theta are uncorrelated then
this last term here disappears and in
this case our estimate is going to be
just the expected value of theta in
other words our estimate doesn't make
any use of the data essentially what's
happening is that a linear estimator
exploits the correlation between the two
random variables to come up with an
estimate but if the two random variables
are uncorrelated then it's noting that
it can do and it does not give us
anything useful
it just reports back the expected value
of theta let us now look at the mean
squared error that's obtained when we
implement this linear estimator let us
write down what this expression is and
to keep things simple let us assume that
we have zero means and zero variances so
just for the purposes of this derivation
and to simplify the algebra we will work
with the zero mean case so in this case
what we have let me first write theta
and then put here the estimator the
estimator is Rho times Sigma Theta Sigma
X times X basically I took this formula
but I put zeros for the expected values
now let us expand this quadratic we
obtain the expected value of theta
squared that's the variance of theta
since we assumed zero means and the
variance is the square of the standard
deviation then we have a cross term it's
going to be twice the expectation of the
product of theta
with this now we can take out this
constant outside of the expectation so
it's 2 Rho Sigma Theta Sigma X and then
we are going to have the expected value
of theta times X because we assume 0
means the expected value of theta times
X is the covariance of theta and X and
the covariance is Rho Sigma theta Sigma
X and finally we have a last term which
is Rho squared Sigma theta squared
divided by Sigma x squared times x
squared we have an expected value so
that's the expected value of x squared
which is just the variance of X or Sigma
x squared okay this looks like a big
mess but in fact we get nice
cancellations this term cancels with
that term this term cancels with that
term we notice that we have sigma theta
squared in each one of those terms so we
can factor them out and then here we
have minus 2 Rho squared plus Rho
squared when we subtract those two terms
were left just with a minus Rho squared
term so after you do that algebra
carefully you find that the answer takes
a very simple form it's 1 minus Rho
squared times the variance of theta I
should add here that this formula
remains valid even without the
assumption that X and theta have 0 means
what's the interpretation of this the
variance of theta describes the initial
uncertainty we have about theta but
after we carry out the estimation the
uncertainty gets reduced and it gets
reduced by a certain factor what is this
factor if Rho is equal to 0 then this
coefficient is 1 and we do not have any
variance reduction after all when Rho is
equal to 0 this estimator is not very
useful it doesn't give us it doesn't
help us
estimate theta better so the expected
value of the squared error is the same
as the variance of theta on the other
hand when Rho is large then this term
here becomes small and it means that the
mean squared error is small in fact
there is an extreme case that's
interesting namely if Rho is equal to 1
in absolute value so if the random
variables are perfectly correlated then
this term here becomes zero and the mean
squared estimation error is 0 which
essentially means that our estimate is
going to be equal to the unknown value
so the special case of a unit
correlation in absolute value
corresponds to a case where we can
perfectly estimate theta using a linear
estimator
so to summarize the correlation
coefficient plays a crucial role in
linear least squares estimation it
determines the form of the estimator and
also it determines how much the
uncertainty in theta will be reduced
through the process of estimation